مشاهدينا خلينا نتهبل لهذه الصور المباشره
الان وبنشوف تحديدا الان امامنا انطلاق
موكب الامير الحسين
والاميره رجوه الان بعد اتمام يعني مراسم
عقد القران بنشوفهم الان في الموكب
بيتجولوا في شوارع الاردن راح يمروا على
سبعه اماكن او مناطق وتحديدا اصلا في الاف
الاردنيين متجمعين بانتظار هذه اللحظات
ومنتظار تحيه الاعاريس
والعروسه طبعا هذا الموكب من التقاليد
الملكيه وهم الان بيتجهوا من قصر زهران
حيث تم عقد القران الى قصر الحسينيه اللي
حيشهد الحفل الكبير اللي مدعو عليه
1700 مدعو طبعا الان الموكب في
العلم العلم الاردني طبعا
محيطه بالسيارات
والسيارات الحمراء اللي هي قلنا انها
حتكون عشرين سياره كلاسيكيه وهي طبعا جزء
من الموكب الاحمر انه هذه السيارات اللي
هي كلاسيكيه القديمه
وسياره العروسين اللي هي عامله كانه
النجمه الموجوده في العالم اذا الان
مشاهدينا نشاهد العريس والعروسه ولي عهد
الاردن الامير الحسين بن عبد الله مع زوجه
الاميره رجوى الحسين طبعا قبل دقائق او
يعني اقل من ساعه صدرت الاراده الملكيه
وتم اعطائها اللقب او تم منحه لقب
الاميره وصاحبه السمو الملكي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طبعا اجواء احتفاليه كبيره
الاحتفال هذا كله
يعني هذا كل الاحتفال كله كان تحت عنوان
نفرح بالحسين صار لنا تقريبا ايام او
اسابيع وبدات معالم هذه الاحتفال تتشكل
صارت هاشتاج نشط بشكل يومي طبعا على مواقع
التواصل وطبعا تزينت كل الاردن بهذا
الاشعار اللي هو طبعا نفرح بالحسين الف
مبروك
للعروسين هذه مشاهد مباشره من الاحتفال
وموكب العروسين